[Música]
donald trump es conocido por ignorar las
normas presidenciales si se niega a
ceder ante joe biden será uno de sus
últimos desaires el actual presidente de
eeuu sigue afirmando que su derrota
electoral es el resultado de una
manipulación a pesar de que no hay
pruebas sobre ello
y cuentan los votos legales yo gano
fácilmente y bueno si cuentan los votos
ilegales pueden intentar robarnos la
elección del action from mars trump está
intentando luchar contra el resultado su
equipo legal está llevando a cabo
demandas en varios estados donde el
conteo de votos fue apretado y sus
partidarios están protestando pero es
muy poco probable que estos esfuerzos
detengan el proceso de transición para
el 8 de diciembre cualquier recuento
estatal o caso judicial debe resolverse
y el 14 de diciembre los estados
certificarán a su respectivo ganador
el 6 de enero el congreso contará los
votos electorales y anunciará los
resultados y yo bailé en prestará
juramento como presidente el 20 de enero
pero y si trump simplemente se niega a
irse
vayan a bromeado acerca de que servicios
secretos sabe cómo sacar a los intrusos
de la casa blanca si trump realmente se
niega a irse así podría ocurrir me
sorprendería mucho si se llegara a eso
porque sería increíblemente humillante
para trump y es difícil imaginar que él
mismo se sometería este tipo de
humillación pero eso es realmente lo que
sucedería dady brieva para ya sea que
trombo conceda o no la constitución de
eeuu lo deja claro el día de la
inauguración son se convertirá en un
expresidente